okay this is from vegas so much ammo
against trump this is vegas insider.com
2024 election betting gods trump's at
the top
plus 275.
dennis desantis guys
that is
very close
very close yeah biden 550 i cannot
believe kamala is fourteen honestly i
can't believe she's four
i don't think she stands a chance zero
uh pence then buddhich then haley then
michelle obama then warren ben tucker
and the rest of the folks
by the way in that i just want to get
your opinion because i i'll give you my
answer in that what is the most
interesting storyline
oh that's michelle obama i do just want
to say one
one thing on the on the previous point
um it to me it is tragic what trump is
doing now because
his legacy is so strong i think even
somebody on the left can say like the
things he did for the country before the
pandemic there was so much there to run
on to brag about and and he's just he's
squandered the whole thing over this
this nonsense and i i i find that to be
a little bit tragic um you're giving me
side eye because you're like what are
you doing for this car
no i'm not saying that they're saying
there's a you have to be very careful in
life
okay
very careful i've had a lot of enemies
over the years
i had a lunch a few weeks ago with one
of my biggest enemies in business okay
and we had lunch and we sat down it was
an incredible lunch we had together okay
fasten to the point where the at the end
the hug was like a brotherly hug and
listen wow we wanted to kill each other
okay this is one of your enemies you're
saying
you don't need to go any deeper than
that because so this is somebody that's
an enemy in business okay
you have to be very careful to not hate
or be envious
and you have to be able to logically
give credit where credits do even if i'm
not a lebron james fan at
all
i give him tremendous credit what he did
with all the odds being against him to
become who he is today with his as a
father as a leader to his family
tremendous credit i don't agree with
what he's saying even saying to griner
if i was her i don't know if i'd come
back to him yeah all the stuff that he
does i don't support any i think too
much bitching but i support the fact
that he's done what he's done so you got
to be careful because for somebody to
become a billionaire
win on tv and to become a president name
me one person that's done that including
reagan he's never done that so his
legacy he's one of a kind just so you
may he's one he's gonna be one of the
most controversial uh most written about
figures in the history of america but
he's one of a kind only one person ever
has become a billionaire one on tv and
become a president only one
person's ever done that not 50
he ain't one in five he's in one of one
okay hate them love them trash them do
whatever you can name you one other
person that's done that you can't do
that so but if you look at this list i
would love
to do a fundraiser at my house i would
do it for number one
i would do for number two
i don't think three and four running i
would do a fundraiser for number six
pete i would do fundraiser for obama
wait you you do pete but not pence i
pen's fine i just don't think pence has
a chance i just don't think pence has a
chance i think pete
could have a chance i think michelle
definitely i don't think uh what's uh is
that warren i think bernie's too old i
think i would do a fundraiser and bring
people to ask real questions i've been
part of these fundraisers before and
it's not like hey what's up can we take
a picture it's not like hey can i get a
picture to post on instagram no it's
like hey so tell me what do you think
about this stuff why are you doing this
like how do you handle a situation like
i want to be able to ask pete a couple
questions i want to be able to ask
michelle a couple questions you know on
and where she's at because there's a
difference between michelle and barack
and 04 one-term senators who are broke
to michelle and barack obama today who
are worth a few hundred
million dollars there's a different
perspective for business so i'd love to
speak to michelle about that and say hey
let's do a fundraiser ask some questions
and i'll bring some people that are from
both sides of the aisle and we'll raise
whatever the amount is 25 bucks ahead 25
i don't know what the dollar amount is
but i would love to do that to see both
sides of the aisle okay to do that so
for me it's not i'm a trump guy i'm a
desantis guy i'm a you know uh uh who's
your guy uh a mansion yesterday i
tweeted something about mansion and i
said the yesterday about mansion uh uh i
said joe manchin
i gotta read this to you because it's so
ironic that you're talking about him
today and this was my tweet yesterday i
said joe mansion someone give joe
manchin a medal of honor okay i think at
the end of the day this guy's going to
get a lot more credit to have kept
america together during because [ __ ]
could be a lot worse if there was not a
mansion today but that's the answer so
but i i think you're the exception and i
don't do this often but i'm gonna give
credit to adam here i
american politics the presidential race
is very much a popularity contest that's
all it is people don't care about
policies you go ask the average american
what policies of trump they like they
can't give you an answer and what i
think is very interesting here is that
nowhere on this list is gavin newsom i
think it's fairly obvious gavin newsom's
going to be the candidate yeah i think
that's who they want i think that's who
they're going to push i think that's who
they're going to have
people don't like kamala people think
pete's a joke
elizabeth warren is she's i think people
see through her um bernie the party
won't let bernie win i think it's
obvious newsome's gonna be the candidate
donald trump cannot beat gavin newsom
andrew cuomo
you don't think trump can be gathered
absolutely not absolutely not i think
people aren't going to care about what
happened in california i think people
are going to look